So, Leute, am Start kann man den Streaming-Rechner anmachen.
Ratet mal, was ich gerade gespielt habe.
Und wer sofort in-Game festgestellt hat, dass ich in-Game bin?
Fortnite, richtig.
Quatsch.
Warzone, nee, auch nicht.
Ich habe Battlefield 3 gespielt.
Ich bin auf den Server gejoint.
Das war in der Sandcrossing.
Haben ein paar Kills gemacht.
Kam der Erste im Chat, Max FPS, Fragezeichen.
Ich weiß nicht, was hier mit den Leuten los ist, warum die mich doch alle kennen.
Aber man muss ja sagen, Battlefield 3 sind wahrscheinlich auch ein paar drauf hängen geblieben.
Und viele haben damals die Videos geguckt bei mir.
Huge.
Terrox hat abonniert, acht Monate.
Prime Subscription.
Huge IQ Subscription.
Hey Max, bei welcher Bank arbeitest du? Jetzt sage ich nicht.
Secret.
Wer hat übermorgen noch IT-Abschlussprüfungen?
Hoffentlich gibt es bestimmt ein paar.
Schriftliche Prüfung oder mündlich Präsentation?
Hehe, relax.
Ich habe meinen Login-Daten.
Ich lade nur nichts hoch.
Schriftlich, Moment, was?
Ihr habt schriftliche Prüfung nach der mündlichen Prüfung?
Was ist denn das für ein komisches System?
Cisco Final Examen, welches?
Welches Cisco?
GH1 ist kein Problem, das kriegst du hin.
Um den Wieso-Teil muss man sich Gedanken machen, den Rest kriegt hin.
Den Rest kriegt man hin.
Der Wiso-Teil ist das Problem.
Wegen Corona, achso.
Ah, verstehe.
Wegen Corona, ja, das leuchtet ein.
Oder auch nicht.
ESO, ja, habe ich auch am Anfang mal ein bisschen gespielt.
Das war von Leuten, teilweise mitentwickelt, die auch bei Dark Age of Camelot dabei waren.
Da dachte ich mir so, hey, könnte ja was werden.
Aber irgendwie war das PvP nicht wirklich zugesagt in ESO.
IT Essentials, also First Level Support.
Oh, First Level Support.
Painstamp, ich fühle den Painstamp gerade.
Massive Painstamp.
Übrigens, wo habe ich denn vorhin gelesen?
Äh, hm.
Ich habe vorhin irgendwas auf Heiseltal gelesen, wo ich gesagt habe, das ist ein bisschen...
Wo ich gesagt habe, das muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Ach ja, die Telekom hier.
Big Brain Move heute.
Die sind der Meinung, wenn man eine geile Lichtershow veranstaltet, wird der Netzausbau besser von.
Das größte 5G-Netz Deutschlands.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein krasses Achievement ist, wenn man das Größte hat.
Von, wenn alle was Kleines haben und man hat halt das Größte vom Kleinen.
Weiß nicht, ob das wahnsinnig so Big Brain ist.
Aber die Lichtershow macht es definitiv besser.
Ja.
Oh, die Musik.
Was bei Golem?
Irgendwo habe ich was gelesen.
Ich weiß leider nicht mehr genau was.
Was ich mir gedacht habe, das muss ich euch zeigen.
Ah ja, das nicht, aber das ist echt...
Wie unbeliebt kann man sich eigentlich machen, ja?
In Zeiten, wo Unternehmen pleite gehen, wo Leute Kurzarbeit machen müssen, wo Leute ihre Arbeit verlieren, wo Leute komplett am Existenz...
Äh, unter dem Existenzminimum rumkrebsen.
Wie dreist kann man...
Oder wie YOLO und scheißegal.
Weltfremd kann man eigentlich sein, dass man auf die Idee kommt, ey, lass mal Rundfunkgebühren erhöhen.
Wie, wie komplett abgehoben, detached, losgelöst von der restlichen Welt kann man eigentlich sein, dass man jetzt die Rundfunkgebühren anhebt.
Das leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Das wollte ich euch aber nicht zeigen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was.
Ja.
Also ich bin immer mehr geneigt dazu, meinen Lastschriftauftrag zu kündigen.
Und am besten noch Barzahlung anzubieten.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, was die machen.
Die können mich ja verklagen.
Wollen sie mal machen.
Ich bezahle ja.
Ihr müsst mir bloß sagen, wo.
Was hältst du von Scrum-Kanban-ETC?
Das kann gut funktionieren, wenn man Leute hat, die wissen, was sie machen.
Und sich nicht zu sehr an irgendwelchen Texten, die super agile Menschen geschrieben haben, hochziehen.
Sondern die das so machen, wie das für das jeweilige Unternehmen passt.
Dann kann das gut funktionieren.
Das Problem ist, dass die meisten agilen Methoden...
...in Deutschland nicht funktionieren.
Oder ich, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Also die meisten agilen Methoden in den alteingesessenen Unternehmen in Deutschland nicht funktionieren.
Scrum, Wikipedia.
So, weil das eine der wenigen Sachen, was sie davon machen.
Also wer sich das hier mal angucken will, das ist ja ein riesen Sammelsurium an Ideen, was man machen kann.
Die meisten machen davon genau zwei Sachen.
Irgendeine Sprintplanung, ohne den Sprint fertig zu machen.
Und einen Daily Stand-Up, wo alle im Kreis stehen und jeder was macht.
Und komplett entgegen der Idee hinter Scrum, läuft es in den meisten alteingesessenen Firmen darauf raus, dass es ein tägliches Stand-Up wird, wo derjenige gewinnt, der am meisten wichtig tut, was er gerade macht.
Also genau das Gegenteil von dem, was das eigentlich sein soll.
Und dementsprechend sagen viele, sie machen es, aber die wenigsten machen es wirklich.
Aber das finde ich komplett detached von der Realität.
Übrigens, das zählt nicht nur zu Scrum.
Das ist ein richtiges Remastered, lohnt sich richtig.
Ich habe mir das Goldbein jetzt schon mit der einen Kampagne fast durch.
Das macht echt Bock.
Das ist mal ein richtig gutes Remastered hier geworden.
Was sagt denn Hacker News heute?
Da habe ich noch gar nicht reingeguckt.
Hacker News.
Okay, Hacker News mit Dark Theme sieht eklig aus.
End-to-End Encryption für Zoom.
Okay, wer verwendet Zoom?
Ja, ich weiß, genug, aber ich nicht.
Okay, Hacker News ist heute nicht so spannend.
Go Generics.
Es wäre wirklich gut, wenn Go es mal hier auf die Reihe kriegen würde mit Generics.
Aber ich glaube da nicht dran.
Weil die ganzen Go-Profis sind ja der Meinung, braucht man nicht.
Generics ist komplett overrated.
Deswegen hat man keine typsicheren, keine typsicheren, ähm, ähm, na.
Keine, jetzt habe ich es, keine typsicheren Collections in Go, wo man mehr als einen Typ reinpacken kann.
Weil sowas wie Object gibt es ja, glaube ich.
In Go gar nicht.
Skype oder Teams?
Teams, Teams, Teams, Teams, Teams.
Auf jeden Fall Teams.
Heute kein Big Brain Chat.
Warum nicht?
Excellent Chat.
So, mal gucken, ob ich was übersehen habe.
Oh, das Chat-Auffälle habe ich vergessen einzubletten.
Stimmt.
Der Chat.
Oje.
Das Wichtigste vom ganzen Stream, weil er ist nicht da.
Ähm.
Wie gesagt.
Wie gesagt, ich bin nicht lang, auch eine Stunde oder so.
Ungefähr.
Nicht, nicht lang.
Ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht on kommen, aber nachdem ich gerade 45 Minuten Runde, irgendwie war das, oder ewig gedauert,
Grand Bazaar 64 Mal in Rush gespielt habe, da war mein Hirn so kaputt, dass ich, äh, keine zweite Runde mehr hingekriegt habe.
Äh, gibt's, gibt's Path of Exile League?
Gibt's Patch Notes?
Oh.
Moment, das muss ich mal kurz reingucken.
Spielt von euch einer Path of Exile?
Vielleicht ist das eine League, wo ich mal wieder richtig reinsuchte.
Mal gucken.
Äh.
Ah.
Ähm.
Mich interessiert eigentlich nur, was sie genervt und gebalanced haben an Skill Balances.
Hier.
Oh.
Oh, ich kann wieder kein Braindead Summoner spielen.
Das ist doch doof.
Braindead Summoner ist meine Lieblingsklasse.
Das kannst du so komplett wie die letzten, wie der letzte Kack-Noob spielen.
Ja, das wissen wir ja schon.
Das Battlefield 6 kein Battlefield 3 Remaster ist.
Schließt ja der Name schon aus.
Ich weiß nicht, was Jack Frags uns hier für Big-Brain-Gedankengänge erzählen will, aber
Battlefield 3 Remaster kann von ...
Die Namensgebung würde ja noch nicht mal im Battlefield-Kreis einen Sinn ergeben, wenn
man Battlefield 3 Remaster Battlefield 6 nennen würde.
Denn Legorasen sind ein Lied, das man im Spiel nicht mehr spielen kann.
Was ist denn das hier für ein Titel?
Das heißt hier dass, was ist das für ein Titel?
Das ist ja so ein Titel, das man immer wieder in einem Spiel spielen kann.
Das heißt hier in Battlefield 3 Remaster es gibt ein Titel, das man im Spiel nicht mehr
spielen kann.
Name schon aus. Ich weiß nicht, was
Jackfrax uns hier für Big Brain
Gedankengänge erzählen will,
aber Battlefield 3 Remaster
kann von... Die Namensgebung
würde ja noch nicht mal im Battlefield-Kreis
einen Sinn ergeben, wenn man Battlefield 3 Remaster
Battlefield 6 nennen würde.
Der Lego-Rasenmäher.
Lol.
Können wir uns mal aufregen über die Samsung-Logik
bei einigen Monitoren? Warum?
Micharo, weshalb?
Achso, du musst den Monitor aufmachen, um den Fuß
komplett zu entfernen. Oh, da muss ich sagen,
das haben die richtig gut gemacht bei dem Monitor hier.
Das ist ja der, den ich mir geholt hab.
Der Fuß...
Der Fuß, den steckst du einfach rein,
drehst einmal rum, er ist dran. Das ist
total toll und easy gemacht.
Und die haben auch überall so rote Markierungen
dran, das ist auch nice. Da kann man
innerhalb von 20 Sekunden den Monitor wieder exakt
so einstellen, wie er war.
Das ist echt huge, huge brain.
Okay, der Matze fragt...
Hey Max, ich möchte
mir ein Raid unter Ubuntu
einrichten. Also, um, um, stimmt,
sorry Leute, ich muss es, muss, ich muss es korrekt,
korrekt aussprechen.
Also, er möchte sich ein Raid
unter Ubuntu einrichten.
Performancegründe.
Welches Raid würdest du empfehlen,
falls ich irgendwann auf 10G umsteige?
Nutzt zur Zeit aber nur HDDs
oder müssen es SSDs sein, um die Geschwindigkeit
zu erreichen? Das kommt auf
die Anzahl der Festplatten an und ob du
hauptsächlich lesen oder schreiben willst und
wie wichtig dir Ausfallsicherheit ist.
Also, du kannst auch eine
Raid 1, also wenn die Lese, also
sequentielle Leseperformance
reicht, dann kannst
du auch ein paar Platten ins Raid 1
hängen.
Raid 1 hast du den Vorteil,
dass du halt, ähm,
dass quasi alle Platten
bis auf eine kaputt gehen können.
Dafür hast du wenig Speicherplatz.
Ähm, und dafür aber ist die
Lesegeschwindigkeit ziemlich schnell.
Schreiben ist nicht schnell.
So, ähm, die nächste Variante
war, du sagst, okay, ein bisschen
mehr Speicherplatz, äh, willst du haben,
dann kannst du dir überlegen, ob du
vielleicht einen Raid 5 oder 6 machst,
wobei man da sagen muss, einen Raid 5
würde ich, sag mal,
mit 3, 4 Platten vielleicht noch
machen, aber mit, äh,
mit mehr Platten würde ich eher einen Raid 6
machen. Da kriegst du dann auch
ordentliche Performance raus. Oder wenn du sagst,
ja, ich will einen ganz guten Kompromiss
haben und ein bisschen YOLO in Kauf
nehmen, was kaputt gehen kann,
dann kannst du auch einen Raid 1, 0 oder einen Raid 10
machen. Raid 10,
ist eigentlich ganz gut. Raid 10 hat ziemlich
gute Performance
und, ähm, Raid 10 können
bis zu 3, also
ne, also, wenn du Glück hast,
ist bei der, bei der dritten Platte,
die kaputt geht, bei 4 erst, erst Schluss.
Ähm, und wenn du Pech
hast bei der, bei der
zweiten.
Einen Ausfall hältst du aber auf jeden
Fall aus. Ja, Raid 10,
1, das ist teuer, ja.
Allerdings ein Raid 6 wird mit großen
Platten auch relativ teuer.
Ich hatte mal einen Raid 6 mit, äh,
damals, glaub, waren das 6 Terabyte
Platten.
Da hatte ich dann 2, 2 mal 6
Terabyte und dann irgendwie noch 5 mal 6
Terabyte. Ähm, das
war auch ganz schön teuer.
Also wenn du, mit 4, wenn du 4 Platten
hast, würde ich mir mal einen Raid 10
überlegen. Mit 4 Platten
kannst du auch einen Raid 5 machen, aber da ist die Schreiben
Performance nicht so groß. Also musst du dir
überlegen, was du halt haben willst, ne.
Also, Lese Performance,
Schreibe Performance, wie viel dürfen kaputt
gehen, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Und eins kann man natürlich unter dem Strich sagen,
SSDs sind schneller als Platten.
Das ist beim Raid nicht anders.
Und wenn du wirklich 10G
vollkriegen willst, dann
ja, also du wirst
vielleicht nicht mit Magnetplatten
komplett vollkriegen, aber das,
aber, aber in die Richtung
schon, also, ähm,
wenn du, wenn du jetzt
ordentliche Platten hast,
Magna, und du nimmst für, für
Nassbetrieb 10 Terabyte Platten, was
haben die heute so, 250 MB die
Sekunde, 300 MB die Sekunde,
da kriegst du das auch, zumindest
Raid Performance mit voll.
Halbwegs. So halbwegs,
ne. 350,
350, oder sagen wir mal 300 mal 4
sind natürlich jetzt nicht, du wirst es nicht
exakt kriegen und es ist auch nicht
ganz 10G, aber fast.
Ähm,
wirst du nicht packen, aber
du kommst in die, in die, in die Richtung,
ja. Wann hast du die letzte
Produktplacement Anfrage bekommen laufen?
Allerdings, die letzte
ordentliche ist schon eine Weile her, weil ich mach ja gerade
auf YouTube nix. Aber ansonsten
bekomm ich täglich irgendeinen Müll, von
irgendwelchen China-Shops und sonst was.
Ja, also wie gesagt, du müsstest dich äußern,
was du eigentlich genau haben willst, da, dazu,
dass man mehr sagen kann.
Was hältst du von der Corona-App?
Ja,
ich finde die Corona-App geben
sich Mühe. Sie geben sich
Mühe, dass, ähm,
ähm, was war hier, genau.
Sie geben sich Mühe, sie versuchen das
möglichst transparent zu machen, äh, haben sie hier
auf GitHub, ähm,
sie versuchen das möglichst transparent zu machen,
sowohl Backend als auch App-Code
ist auf GitHub,
wo ich mir nicht, wo ich mir nicht sicher
bin, ist, ob mal irgendjemand überprüft
hat, ob die, ob die iOS und die Android-App
auch wirklich die ist, die im Store ist,
keine Ahnung, und ob die wirklich das
im Backend einsetzen, was hier oben so ist, das kann man
natürlich letztendlich auch nicht wirklich überprüfen,
aber sie geben sich wirklich
Mühe, sie, sie, sie sind auch relativ
transparent und sie versuchen es wirklich,
diesmal ganz gut zu machen, nach dem ersten
Fiasko mit der, mit der App
vom Robert-Koch-Institut, das war ja voll für den Arsch.
Auf der anderen Seite
traue ich weder der Telekom-SAP
und die Kombination SAP-Telekom-
Bundesregierung, äh, wirklich
großartig über den Weg, und
ich glaube, die
Einschätzung vieler
Leute ist verkehrt, also,
wir sind ja gerade aktuell wieder an
dem Punkt, dass Leute, die die Corona-App nicht
verwenden wollen, äh, quasi
ausgelacht werden, wie so nach dem, oh, oh, oh,
lull, Aluhutmann, oder so,
ähm, und so nach dem Motto,
ja, Datenschutz ist ja gar nicht das Problem,
da muss ich sagen, das stimmt, die Corona-App
sammelt relativ, relativ wenig,
war, gut, die war teuer wie Sau,
die sammelt relativ wenig, macht das Ganze
anonym, also, um Datenschutz-Sachen
denke ich, muss man sich da nicht so
viel Gedanken machen, äh, eher
ob es irgendwelche Bluetooth-Probleme gibt, aber
das liegt jetzt nicht wirklich an der Corona-App,
äh, ich, ich glaube, es liegt an
was anderem, dass die Leute die Corona-App
nicht haben wollen. Es wurden,
ähm, die letzten Jahre
so viel
Internet, beziehungsweise
technikfeindliche Politik gemacht,
und, ähm,
so viele Sachen in den Sand gesetzt, oder so
viel entschieden, gegen das, was die Leute
haben wollten, und gleichermaßen
gibt es so wenig Grundbildung, was IT
anbelangt in Deutschland, dass die meisten
Leute das, glaube ich, gar nicht richtig einschätzen können.
Also, wenn man die letzten 15
Jahre konsequent Politik gemacht hat, gegen
Technik, gegen Internet, gegen so ziemlich alles Moderne,
äh, fängt man mit
Gesundheitskarte, neuem Personalausweis,
Bundestrojaner, Artikel 13,
alles Mögliche, dann muss man
sich nicht wundern, wenn
die Leute einem nicht glauben, dass man
in der Lage ist, sowas hinzubekommen,
und man muss sich nicht wundern, wenn
die meisten Leute
nicht über die notwendigen
Techniken, technischen
Grundlagen im Hirn verfügen,
diese Sache überhaupt richtig einschätzen
zu können. Du musst dich nicht wundern, du kannst
nicht 15, 20 Jahre lang Technik,
Internet, alles vernachlässigen,
und, äh, erwarten,
dass die Leute nicht misstrauisch werden,
vor allem, weil es jede Menge Sachen gab, die auch
gegen sie entschieden wurden. Da muss man
sich nicht wundern. Also, mich wundert es
nicht, dass viele Leute sagen, oh nee, die Corona
will ich mir nicht installieren.
Kann ich nachvollziehen. Es gibt
jetzt kein
offensichtlichen Grund, warum
man das nicht will, wenn man sich das anguckt,
aber ich glaube, viele Leute sind im
Kopf mittlerweile einfach auf
dem Stand, dass sie sagen, alles, was mit Technik
und sonst was zu tun hat, trau ich unserer
Bundesregierung nicht zu, ähm,
zumal auch in der Vergangenheit vieles gegen
uns entschieden wurde. Wie gesagt, Richtung
Bundestrojaner, Artikel 13,
immer mehr Überwachung, also Sachen, die
Leute eigentlich überhaupt nicht wollen, Störerhaftung
fürs WLAN,
und das sind alles solche Geschichten,
wo, was halt absolut kein
Vertrauen in die, in die, äh,
Skills
da, der, der Entscheidungsträger
äh,
besetzt, ja. Dazu
kommt noch,
was passiert am Ende mit der Corona-App,
ja, also wenn jemand auf dem Handy drauf
ist, vielleicht kommt dann jemand auf die Idee und
sagt, ah, das können wir jetzt doch irgendwie als, als, ähm,
halben Bundestrojaner
verbrauchen, gebrauchen,
das ist natürlich alles Mutmaßung
für irgendwo gewisserweise auch Verschwörungstheorie,
aber ich kann das heute keinem
mehr übel nehmen, nach 15
Jahre Technik, Internet, feindlicher
Politik, wenn der keinerlei Vertrauen
darin mehr hat. Das
hat nix, denke ich, bei den meisten
Leuten mit Aluhuhn oder sonst was zu tun,
den meisten fehlt einfach die grundlegend
technisches Verständnis, dass sie überhaupt
nachvollziehen können, was es überhaupt
heißt, Open Source auf GitHub.
Die meisten Leute haben doch gar keinen blassen Schimmer.
Geh mal auf die Straße und frag
jemand, was bedeutet es,
dass die Corona-App Open Source auf GitHub ist.
So, mehr hörst du da nicht.
Du hast keine Ahnung, dass wir die wissen, überhaupt nicht
vor Wort und sprichst. So, und nachdem
ab, nachdem technische
Grundlagen in Deutschland zum größten Teil
nicht existieren im Kopf der Leute,
wundert's mich nicht.
Die denken doch irgendwas mit
Habt, das muss Porno sein, genau.
Die sollen
deinem Stream-Chat scheuen. Ja, dann
werden sie natürlich Big Brain, das ist klar.
So, deswegen denke ich, das hat
alles nix damit zu tun, wie die
jetzt da teilweise
die Idioten auf Twitter wieder rumlästern
so nach dem Motto, aha, Aluhuhn-Träger,
Verschwörungstheoretiker. Ne, die Leute
sind nach 15 Jahre Technik, Internet, feindlicher
Politik einfach total verunsichert
und haben kein Vertrauen
mehr und ich kann es keinem übel nehmen,
bei dem ganzen
Scheiß, der da passiert ist in den letzten
Jahren.
Das gibt so viel
Infrastrukturausbau im Arsch, die ganze
Störerhaftung-Geschichte weder in Artikel 13,
Bundestrojaner-Gesundheitsakte,
Personalausweis, es gibt so viele
Fail-Projekte, wo du hinguckst
oder Projekte gegen das,
was die Leute wollen. Ich nehm's echt
keine Möbel.
Wolle sagt, er wollte, hat jemand auf Twitter gefunden,
der wissen wollte,
ob das Rechenzentrum ISO-zertifiziert ist.
Exzellente Frage.
Huge Question.
So, und
ja, das ist
der Grund, warum ich denke,
man kann's den Leuten gar nicht mal so sehr
übel nehmen.
Wer ist Attila Hildemanns?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ist der eher Pogchamp oder eher
Painschamp?
Wer ist das?
Kann man überhaupt danach suchen,
ohne dass man jetzt irgendwo rauskommt, wo
gleich Monka Toss,
äh, wo hab ich auch Monka Toss ist?
Hard Pain, okay.
Veganer Aluhut-Koch.
Ich hab ja schon mal gesagt, wie ich
gegen die prinzipielle Einteilung der Leute
so, äh, zu Aluhut stehe.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht, keine Ahnung,
ich kenn ihn nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich Aluhut ist.
Ähm,
aber wenn er was von Echsenmenschen
erzählt, dann ist es auf jeden Fall Aluhut.
Der Echsenmensch-Check
ist für mich der Aluhut-Check.
Wenn mir irgendeiner wirklich erzählen will, dass Obamas
Bodyguard-Echsenmensch war, dann ist vorbei.
Ah, Flacherde ist auch noch,
Flacherde geht auch noch.
Flacherde ist auch, äh, Aluhut-Check.
Ah, äh, okay, 5G und
Corona-Masten ist auch, ist auch Aluhut-Check,
ja, das stimmt. Ja.
Echsenmenschen sind auch das harmloseste,
okay.
Gut, es gibt genug Leute, die haben
einen Knall. Aber trotzdem, ich kann es nur oft genug
sagen, auch Leute, die den Knall haben,
lohnt es sich manchmal zuzuhören, weil sie
was Gescheites sagen können. Ich kenn den Typ nicht,
keine Ahnung. Äh, ja, das
Bill Gates eher in allem schuld ist, ist
ja klar. Läuft, läuft eigentlich
die Corona-App auch
auf Windows-Phone?
Nicht Cortana-App.
Corona-App-Store.
Okay, Achtung.
Gucken wir jetzt mal. Corona.
Okay, ich suche
nach Corona und finde Dress-Up-Rapunzel.
Was ist das
für ein Drecks-Igitt?
Was ist das?
Der Windows-Store.
Hahaha.
Ist euer Ernst?
Okay, hat das Bewertung? Reviews?
Oh, nee, hat's nicht. Alles klar.
Geh mal nach Corona, so findet man im Windows-Store
nix. Na, auch gut.
Lad's dir runter. Nee, das kommt nicht auf
meine Platte. Wer weiß, was da alles drin ist.
Lies mal
meinen Kommentar. Äh,
wo? Ah,
schau dir mal die Schweizer App an.
Ist super dezentralisiert und wurde von der
ETH Zürich entwickelt.
Ähm, Apple, Google
haben extra dafür eine Schnittstelle eingerichtet.
Excellent.
Ja, die Schweizer wissen halt, wie es geht.
Und die Schweizer sind wahrscheinlich schon seit drei Wochen fertig damit.
Ist die ETH Zürich
nicht das, wo Einstein auch war?
Damals hieß es noch ein bisschen anders.
Aha, da sind die Schweizer hier.
Sieht doch relativ ähnlich
aus zu uns. Kommt eine Android-App,
eine iOS-App, eine Android-App
und eine Backend-Geschichte.
Ganze App, ganze
Java-Crap da.
Ja, geh fort. Ähm,
ja, ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass die Schweizer
das ordentlich hinkriegen. Schweizer sind ja sehr
gründlich, was sowas angeht.
Basieren die nicht alle
auf dem gleichen Prinzip? So weiß ich,
soweit ich weiß, schon.
Diese ganze, ähm, äh,
Epidemie, Pandemik
API-Geschichte ist eine Sache, die von
Google und Apple bereitgestellt
wird. Ist vollkommen egal, welche App man
verwendet. Die App ist
im Endeffekt einfach nur Frontend.
Für den ganzen Kram.
Antesten bitte.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Programmier mal einfach. Warum sollte ich denn sowas
machen? Äh, wie gesagt,
ähm, ich hab ja jetzt genug zur Corona-App
ausgelassen.
Man sollte, denke ich, trotzdem
für Kritik offen sein. Also
auch, wie gesagt, auch wenn ich denke, dass
man die Corona-App relativ bedenkenlos
installieren kann, ähm,
wenn da Leute Kritik dran üben,
kann man sich das trotzdem mal anhören, ja.
Ich finde schon, dass es da noch ein paar offene Fragen gibt.
Zum Beispiel, was passiert mit der App
nach dem Ablauf?
Also sprich, mit den Installationen, wenn Corona rum ist.
Was, was passiert damit? Gibt's da schon irgendwelche
Regelungen für, ähm, wie sieht's
aus mit, äh, Zwangs-App?
Wie sieht's aus mit Nachteilen, die man eventuell hat,
wenn man die App nicht verwendet? Also es gibt schon
ein paar Kritikpunkte, ein paar offene Fragen, die jetzt
weniger an der App selbst liegen, sondern
eher halt an, an, an dem ganzen
Drumherum. Also ich denke, das ist es
sich wert, sich das mal anzuhören, was
da Leute, die da Kritik dran üben,
zu sagen haben. Ähm,
an der App selbst, denke ich, gibt's
recht wenig auszusetzen. Die macht einen ganz,
ganz guten Eindruck.
Ähm, installierst du dir die Corona-App?
Nee, kann ich nicht. Ich hab ein iPhone 6.
Ich hab ein iPhone 6, kann mir die
Corona-App nicht installieren.
Außerdem geh ich doch eh nicht aus dem Haus.
Wenn ich nicht grad streame, spiele
oder Homeoffice mache, geh ich höchstens mal
bisschen spazieren oder was einkaufen.
Klar, dabei kann auch was passieren, aber
ich hab kein Handy, wo's drauf läuft.
Zumindest nichts, keins, was ich mitnehme.
Doch, ich hab ein neues iPhone. Ich hab hier ein
iPhone 6 und ein iPhone XS.
iPhone 6 und
iPhone XS. Allerdings nehm ich das
iPhone 6 mit, weil's leichter ist und da ist die
SIM-Karte drin. Ja.
Die API.
Wie interessant ist, was mit der Corona-App
passiert.
Wie gesagt, ich verstehe Leute, die
misstrauisch sind.
Im Hinblick, was
mit
Bundestrojaner Artikel 13, alle möglichen Sachen gelaufen
sind für die Leute. Okay. Ähm, was habt
ihr eigentlich mit der App vor? Ich meine, ein Update
zu pushen über den App Store, was dann vielleicht die App
zweckentfremdet, ist ja nicht,
komplett auszuschließen. Ich
sag jetzt nicht, dass es
sonderlich wahrscheinlich ist, aber
auszuschließen ist das nicht.
Das ist ja fast nix auszuschließen.
Deswegen kann ich's verstehen, wie gesagt, wenn Leute kritisch
sind dabei. Ist dann halt dead,
wenn die API entfernt wird. Warum? Man könnte doch einfach
ein Update pushen über den App Store
und dann die App was anderes
machen lassen. Sei es so, wie Cristiano
Ronaldo Monero meinen.
Was ist Ripple 20?
Ripple 20.
Ripple 20 klingt, klingt irgendwie
ein bisschen, auch nicht.
Äh, das ist wohl wahr.
Da hat, da hat Heise recht.
Internet der Dinge, auch
zum größten Teil Internet of Shit.
Ja gut, das verwenden wir alle nicht.
Ich glaub, der ESP verwendet,
äh, ich weiß nicht, was der ESP für ein TCP
Implementierung verwendet.
Max, hast du gesehen, dass es ein neues iPhone SE
gibt? Ja. Ja,
Almighty Buddha, das kann ich verstehen.
Äh,
und was ist da von
betroffen? Keine ESPs, oder?
Die ESPs haben irgendeine China-TCP-Implementierung
wahrscheinlich, die keiner kennt.
Ne.
Shodav!
Kogas!
Nice, zwei Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Brain Subscription.
Ist ESP nicht der Radarhack
in Shootern? Keine Ahnung.
Ne, das war X22, war das.
X22
war die Geschichte. Weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt.
Es trendet eigentlich
diese Woche auf GitHub, wo wir gerade mal dabei sind.
Und, Explore,
Trending, Trending.
Habt ihr irgendwelche Fragen
übersehen? Nope.
Habe ich ein XR oder ein XS?
Ich weiß
das nicht.
Was sind das kleinere davon?
XR oder XS?
XS, dann habe ich wahrscheinlich ein XS.
Dann habe ich
wahrscheinlich ein XS. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe es auch
gerade nicht hier, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Dann habe ich wahrscheinlich
ein XS.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Hardware wird doch mehr oder weniger das gleiche sein, oder?
Äh, Chefsessel,
es liegt daran, weil die Google
Android APIs kacke sind.
Damit du Bluetooth
einschalten kannst, beziehungsweise damit du
Bluetooth verwenden kannst, muss Standort
Ermittlung eingeschaltet sein.
Ohne Standortermittlung erlaubt Google
nicht das Zugreifen auf Bluetooth.
Das ist
Google-Logik. Da können die Corona-App
Leute tatsächlich gar nichts dafür.
Aber was du machen kannst, ist,
du kannst es erlauben
und an GPS einfach global abschalten.
Dann funktionieren
keine Orten. Aber du kannst natürlich
auch kein GPS-Zeug mehr durchführen.
Warum?
Das habe ich ehrlich gesagt bis heute nicht verstanden.
Warum man unter Android
GPS und Bluetooth
gekoppelt hat. Leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Das ist wirklich
richtig low-brain.
Ja, dann sollten sie
vielleicht nicht Standortermittlung, sondern
sie sollten vielleicht GPS und Bluetooth trennen.
Sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Varianten
zur Standortermittlung. Theoretisch kannst du mit
WLAN auch Standort ermitteln.
Du kannst mit
erstaunlich vielen Sachen Standort ermitteln.
Und sei es nur
die Kombination
von ein paar Sachen.
Unterhose.
Äh, halt
eine Unterhose.
Oh je, das...
Sirius Max schlägt vor, wir sollen dieses Video hergucken.
Wir haben nicht viel Zeit, Leute. Wir müssen
uns heute die Sachen, die wir uns angucken, weise aus.
Wählen. Triggert mich das Video,
wenn ich sehe. Der Titel,
der Titel ist schon was, wo ich wahrscheinlich wieder richtig
drauf abgehen werde. Also,
man weiß ja,
also, Leute, äh, äh,
wie heißt Faustregel, Handregel,
Daumenregel, ne, wie sagt man denn, Faustregel?
Also so, ähm,
so genereller Advice
von mir. Wenn
in einem Videotitel oder auch in
in Überschriften, wenn in
Überschriften, Faustregel, genau,
wenn in Überschriften ein Fragezeichen,
ist, dann ist zu 99 die Antwort
nein. Ihr könnt das ja mal
überprüfen und ich sag euch, ihr liegt
wirklich zu 95% richtig.
Ist in der Überschrift ein Fragezeichen,
ist die Antwort darauf nein.
Zu 95%.
Und
in dem Fall kann ich die Frage schon beantworten,
nein, ist es
nicht. Natürlich, wenn man
das weiß, kann man Sachen so formulieren, dass es
passt, aber das ist ja nicht die Absicht von
denen. Okay, okay,
wir gucken es uns an, ist gut.
Was ist das für ein beknackter Vergleich?
Also, first zu einem
usable desktop, würde ich sagen, ist Linux
schneller. Die Installation,
wenn man beispielsweise ein fertiges Linux Mint
oder Ubuntu nimmt, mit Windows 10, die Installation
ist ungefähr gleich schnell,
allerdings muss man unter Windows 10 erstmal
drei Stunden Cortana und Datenschutz
Geschiss durchklicken.
You're gonna install Windows on that
PC, I'm gonna install Linux on this one.
So, it's a race?
First to a usable desktop
wins. Ready?
Okay, well, come on, you put obstacles in my
way. Okay, fine.
Schrei nicht so laut, Alter.
I'm going. Three, two,
one.
Go Windows.
Gave yourself a head start.
I did not.
Video evidence, we pressed it at the same time.
Pressed enter, I hit control alt delete.
I reset the board.
Die müssen bei allem immer so ein
Gefühl von Eile
vermitteln in diesen Videos.
Als würde es jetzt drauf ankommen,
ob er schneller was installiert hat.
It's what's called a throbber.
It's called a throbber, is it?
I got another throbber to show you.
Actually, I'm just flexing my muscles.
No, I don't want to see what's new from Windows.
Come on!
Are you supporting remote workers?
Smart to play can happen.
Okay.
And distros based on it.
It's fully usable.
Oh, es geht schon weiter.
Play experience.
It's at the point where I'd argue that it's even easier to do than Windows now.
I mean, you saw for yourself.
This is fully usable.
This has a driver and everything.
For real.
If you give it a try.
Ja, und dafür gibt's keine Spiele, die gescheit laufen.
You'll be up and running.
Okay, es gibt mittlerweile mehr als früher, aber gut ist was anderes.
Proof and gaming capable OS in a few minutes like I was.
What about the elephant in the room?
Ich meine ganz ehrlich, es ist doch vollkommen egal, wie schnell man das installiert.
Es macht doch überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob man jetzt das Ganze in einer Viertelstunde
installiert hat oder in einer halben Stunde.
Man installiert, wir sind doch nicht mal zu Windows 98 Zeiten, wo man permanent sein Betriebssystem
neu installiert.
Ist doch vollkommen wurscht.
Selbst eine halbe Stunde versus zwei Stunden ist doch egal, solange der Kram nachher stabil
läuft und man das damit, was man machen möchte, am besten machen kann.
Support for your games and stuff.
I mean, it's not like everything runs on Linux.
Ja, true.
Richtig.
But significantly more stuff runs on Linux.
Ja, true.
I've got a pretty big library.
Also, wenn man das über den gesamten Steam-Spielekatalog nimmt und eventuell auch nicht so anspruchsvoll
ist, was runs bedeutet, dann mag das rein mathematisch gesehen zutreffen.
Eventuell, weiß ich nicht.
Wenn man das allerdings auf große Titel mal einschränkt, also das die Titel, die halt
eben auch Millionen Leute von Rechner locken, nehmen wir mal beispielsweise Fortnite, Warzone,
was auch immer, was gibt's denn da sonst noch, GTA 5 oder so.
Spätestens bei Multiplayer ist unter Linux mit Vine halt nun mal Schluss.
Kannst du vergessen.
... at home, including popular titles like GTA 5.
Ja, du kannst Singleplayer spielen, sehr gut.
... Proton Compatibility Layer was super cool, when we first looked at it, translating Direct
Decks, Windows-only games to Vulkan on Linux, and between the official one and tweaked community
versions like those from TK Glitch and Glorious Eggman ...
Also im Vergleich zu früher funktioniert die Sachen wunderbar.
Früher haben die Sachen ja quasi gar nicht funktioniert.
Mittlerweile sind sie ja schon ... Mittlerweile ist im Vergleich zu früher ganz toll.
Trotzdem ...
... dann muss man sich das mal anschauen.
Ja.
Wenn man das mal vergleicht, mit was es alles gibt, ist es halt trotzdem nicht der Wahnsinn.
... 9% of the top 1000 games on Steam are actually rated gold or better on ProtonDB, and most of the ones that don't work ...
End of Function Zero ist bei mir auch so, ich verwende auf der Arbeit auch nur Linux.
Daheim habe ich halt hier meinen Hybrid aus Windows mit Linux, VM, einzig und allein wegen Spielen.
... DRL or anti-cheat related games ...
Und Video-Zeug.
Right.
I mean, the problem is, there's nothing that Valve or the Proton team can do about deliberately
Linux-incompatible DRM, like how the Denuvo anti-cheat made Doom Eternal unplayable.
Ja, genau.
But the good news is that they actually came out and said that going forward, Denuvo anti-cheat
will support Linux.
One theory is that this change in stance could have to do with cloud gaming services
using Linux as their personal choice.
Das ... Ja.
Das habe ich ja auch schon vor zwei Jahren oder so gesagt, dass ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir
... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn
wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ... Wenn wir ...
Nvidia's RTX-Raytracing, for example, hasn't been enabled yet.
Ja.
Yeah, but to be fair to Nvidia, they have been rolling out additional raytracing extensions
here and there, which is a key step to enabling the functionality later on.
And there's some other big news, too.
For some gamers, check this out, Linux actually meets their needs better than Windows does,
and not just by a little bit.
For 16-Bit-Retro-Gamers, for example, Wine offers better compatibility and stability
without having to run games in a virtual machine.
And get this, we've recorded runs with less old games running faster on Linux than on
an identical Windows machine.
Like, that's not just some random game that no one plays.
Das stimmt, da muss man sich aber ganz genau den Fall angucken, wo das herkommt.
Es kann nämlich durchaus sein, dass manche Effekte
unter den Windows-Retro-Gamers nicht so gut funktionieren, wie es bei Windows-Retro-Gamers
oder Linux nicht funktionieren, und deswegen das Cap schlicht und greifend schneller läuft.
Aber, kommt von Fall zu Fall an.
Go ahead.
This is actually a game that Tim Sweeney published.
Is it really?
Well, it's an Epic-Mega-Games-Game.
Okay, it's older than me.
Yes.
Well, 1993.
So, not quite.
But I was seven.
This was possible thanks to Valve's ACO Shader Compiler, which is designed to improve performance
on GPUs that use Mesa, like AMD's Vega and Navi-based cards.
And that's even with Proton overhead.
Let's take a look.
Linux GTA 5!
Woo!
Doesn't make you a better driver, that's for sure!
Dang!
Oh, lucky.
My car tipped over.
In all seriousness, though.
Back when this game came out, I probably would have said, haha, AAA-Gaming on Linux?
Yeah.
Please.
Es hat sich, es hat sich tatsächlich die letzten Jahre wirklich viel getan.
Huge, huge 60 FPS.
Das rutscht.
Huge 60 FPS.
Let's go.
Das rutscht.
Da價ht auch die
Diese Spiele noch bestimmt 4K.
Das kann sein.
Allerdings, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen 4K oder flüssigen FPS, würde ich immer flüssige
FPS nehmen.
Hm.
Wie bin ich?
Tja, okay.
Also, egal ob Grafikkarte, man installiert einfach die Abgeordneten-Card, man installiert
Steam, installiert Spiele.
install games and play games. If you're on AMD, enable ACO and Steam's launch options for titles that support it and
you're laughing. As for NVIDIA users,
don't stress out too much. NVIDIA's drivers aren't as good as they could be, if they were more open like EMDs.
But they also aren't as bad as people make them out to be.
Beste Grafiktreiber unter Linux sind tatsächlich Intel, aber Intel GPUs sacken halt.
NVIDIA support their respective adaptive refresh technology on Linux now, with no additional installs required.
If you want to quantify your Linux gaming performance, even that is getting easier. Windows tools like Fraps or Frameview won't run,
but Mango HUD by flightlessmango works absurdly well.
Warum verwenden die nicht, warum verwenden die nicht Keck-FPS?
Oder wie haben wir unser Tool genannt?
FPS Keck oder irgendwie sowas? Die sollen Keck-FPS verwenden.
Das beste Tool dafür.
... configurable Rivetuner-esk-overlay, and you can upload logs to the website and have it automatically generate graphs for frame rates, frame times,
1% minimums, pretty much everything you need. Honestly, if it logged more information like CPU and GPU temperatures,
we'd probably switch over to it instead of what we're using in Windows.
It's really good. By the way guys, you might take for granted the controller that Anthony is using
over there, but look closely here.
Controller support is nothing special in Linux. Dualshock 3, Dualshock 4, Xbox 360, Xbox One, 8-Bit-Doh,
none of those require any configuration or special drivers, even over Bluetooth.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Riesenvorteil, den man oftmals unter Linux hat. Wenn der Kram unterstützt wird, dann geht er meistens einfach, ohne dass man großartig was machen muss.
Problematisch wird's, wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Look at this.
Even the Xbox One wireless adapter, low-latency wireless operation for four controllers off a single dongle, just like it does on Windows.
And the Dualshock 4's touchpad even works as a mouse.
Speaking of Dualshock 4, we've actually got a video on the pipeline where we play around with gyro aiming for games. Get subscribed so you don't miss it.
What is this?
Nothing, nothing, get away.
Nope.
Haha, you have to social distance, so if I come over here, you have to move.
Absolut nicht gestellt.
Open RGB.
Open RGB Control on Linux?
Yep.
Ja, warum nicht?
Open RGB is available on both Windows and Linux.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste. Das Allerwichtigste.
Wenn RGB nicht geht, hat man ja schon mal 20 FPS weniger. Das kann ich verstehen. Das ist ganz essentiell.
Maybe RAM, motherboard lighting, GPUs and even stuff like Corsair Lighting Notes.
Despite all the work that's already gone into it though, it's a little bit basic right now and it's a pain to get running on Ubuntu at the moment.
But for simple lighting effects, it's quite enough.
Alright, Hotshot.
How about VR?
I want to get in some Beat Saber Action Penguin Edition.
That's tricky.
HTC Vive and Valve Index have both worked for a while now because Valve officially supports them in Steam.
But the OpenHMD driver for Oculus and PSVR is currently missing some rather major features.
And the virtual desktop experience and reprojection are cited as major issues by all Linux VR users.
That's a real bummer because I use virtual desktop a ton.
Even if it's just to, like, fix something about my stream while I'm playing or whatever the case may be.
And if, aside from gaming, you're a content creator, you might have a hard time switching to Linux full-time, even if all your games work.
The Adobe Suite, which, as we made a video about recently,
Es gibt halt ein paar Sachen, die für viele Leute halt absolut Killer sind. Die brauchen sie.
Wie gesagt, wenn mein Zeug, alles was ich machen würde unter Linux, funktionieren würde,
da würde ich doch kein Windows machen.
Wozu sollte ich das denn machen?
Bin doch nicht bescheuert.
Aber leider ist das halt aktuell noch nicht so.
Ja, gut.
Ja, seit 10 Jahren.
15 Jahre.
Wow.
Morgen, Kais.
Ja, geh zurück.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich bin gut, ich bin in Ordnung.
Einige Entwickler sind ein bisschen Dicks darüber.
Und ich verstehe die Anliegen der sterbenden Linux-Veteranen.
Sie denken, dass sich Proton als ein Krutch aufbauen könnte,
die Entwickler von nativen Linux-Games auszunutzen.
Aber für mich sehe ich Proton und Wine generell als mehr als...
Ich scheiß auf die Hardcore-Linux-Fans, ganz ehrlich.
Die haben auch in der Vergangenheit gesagt, dass man so, dass zum Beispiel Plug & Play,
komplett nützlich.
Wer möchte denn bitte schön, dass der Rechner was automatisch macht?
Ich möchte das alles von Hand vergeben.
Da gibt es öfters, gibt es Tonnen, Tausende Diskussionen von irgendwelchen Hardcore-Linux-Fans,
die immer mit anfangen, das braucht man nicht, das ist doch für Noobs und sonst was.
Dann sollen sie Gentoo verwenden und erstmal 45 Minuten kompilieren,
wenn ihnen einer einen Anhang für Open Office schickt, meinetwegen.
Alles okay.
... Developers can support, that requires little additional effort
and allows for the user base to grow.
And the more the user base grows,
the more accessible everything becomes.
So, at this point, the call to action for you guys is really simple.
Where did it go?
There it is.
Pick up a USB stick and give it a try.
You can run it right off the USB without installing it on your main drive,
like I did in this recent video,
where Windows just straight up wouldn't run my weird Chinese motherboard
that had a baked-on graphics card.
But Linux would.
Go check out that video.
And try it.
Hardcore-Linux-Fans,
play SuperTux-Card.
SuperTux-Card, bestes Game.
Without SuperTux-Card, nothing works.
Let's do a round.
SuperTux-Card, excellent.
We drive a SuperTux-Card.
SuperTux-Card.
Now I'm saying Linux-Gaming.
Huge Linux-Gaming.
Oh, what?
Ah, excellent, of course you're not allowed to go in there.
SuperTux-Card, huge.
Massive, massive gamer.
Linux, eindeutig beste Gaming-Plattform.
Ich mein, wer braucht denn bitte schön was anderes,
wenn er SuperTux-Card hat?
Insane!
Ist Wubblos ein guter Streamer?
Nee, auf keinen Fall.
RGB-Klo.
Mein Klo hat ne blaue LED, die angeht, wenn man sich draufsetzt, dass man nachts ein bisschen
was sieht.
Oh, der Ventress hat gesappt, zwei Monate, exzellent, da muss ich auch Prime-Suppen bei
ihm wieder.
Excellent Subscription, Dankeschön, RGB-Klo haben wir schon.
Ja, wie hieß das Tool nochmal?
Hat jemand gemerkt, wie das Tool hieß?
Ich kann mir das gerade mal angucken, OpenRGB oder irgendwie sowas, ne?
Was da?
Oh, GitLab, das ist wieder irgendeiner, der die Hälfte auf GitLab umgezogen hat.
Aurora Open, das habe ich sogar schon mal ausprobiert, das war wirklich ganz gut.
Die ist außerhalb vom Klo, End of Function Zero.
Das habe ich sogar schon mal ausprobiert, das ist wirklich ganz gut gewesen.
Allerdings haben sie damals, glaube ich, nicht mein Cosaar.
Äh, Cosaar Keyboard unterstützt, aber habe ich jetzt ja nicht mehr, ich habe jetzt
nur noch Logitech.
Müsste man echt mal ausprobieren, aber ich habe ja kaum noch RGB.
An der Maus habe ich die Beleuchtung komplett aus und an der Tastatur habe ich konstant
auf Blau stehen.
Ey, choose my name, vergiss es, ich habe eine Sache bisher gemacht mit GTK unter Windows
und es ist einfach grausam, bis das funktioniert.
Grausam.
Das heißt, dass man auch die MSYS 2 GTK Libraries gar nicht richtig verwenden kann, weil man
braucht unter Windows in der Regel keine GCC Libraries, sondern Visual Studio C Compiler
Libraries.
Und das sind die MSYS 2 GTK Pakete nicht.
Es ist voll für den Arsch, GTK unter Windows.
Das nächste Problem, was du hast, ist, wenn du startest, dass GTK der Meinung ist, seinen
eigenen Fensterrahmen malen zu müssen.
Das muss er dann erstmal in zig Config-Sachen ausstellen, dass er das macht.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
So, ich wollte mal gucken, was gerade auf GitHub trendet.
Wir sind ja leider, haben ja heute nicht so viel Zeit.
Was trendet denn auf GitHub this week?
YOLOv5.
Was ist YOLOv5?
YOLOv5, PyTorch und CoreML IOS.
Ich habe legit keinen Plastenschimmer.
Irgendwas chinesisches.
YOLOv5, YOLOvL, YOLOv5M, YOLOv5...
Object Detection Methods.
Ah, das könnten sie vielleicht da oben hinschreiben, dass man weiß, was es ist.
Vanilla Web Projects.
Das ist, das könnte ein gutes Beispiel sein für Leute, die im Stream immer fragen, Max,
mit was, mit welchem Programmierprojekt soll ich anfangen?
Li-Han-Code.
So viel chinesisches Sachen auf GitHub.
JSON for Modern C++.
Okay, ich würde mich gerade mal schocken, Leute.
Wie macht man JSON in Modern C++?
Example.
Ja, sieht schon mal ganz toll aus.
Sample.
Tja, wenn man keine ordentlichen escape, escapte, schon standardmäßig escapte Strings hat in
der Programmiersprache, dann sieht das halt so aus.
Haben wir hier einen Examples-Ordner?
Nee.
Das ist auch sowas, was mir in C++-Projekten oftmals aufgefallen ist.
Ja.
Wenn man in C++-Projekten oftmals auf den Keks geht, dass die keinen Examples-Ordner haben.
Okay.
Ah ja.
Es sieht relativ normal aus.
Gar nichts, wo ich mich jetzt wahnsinnig drüber beschweren könnte.
JSON-Pointer.
Es sieht halt relativ normal aus.
Außer, dass wieder so komische Sachen da drin sind.
Aber gut.
Es sieht nach einer halbwegs brauchbaren JSON-Library für C++ aus.
Tja, gut.
Warum nicht?
Ich meine, sonst noch hier.
Playwright Note Library to Automate Chrome Webkit.
Okay.
Das ist für Leute, die kein Puppeteer verwenden wollen und alle Browser automatisieren wollen.
Go plus Language for Data Science.
Okay.
Es ist Go mit Zusatz Go.
Double Go.
Irgendwie ist diesmal nichts Spannendes drin.
Xamarin Forms ist auch was.
Da mache ich einen großen Bogen drum.
Irgendwie nichts Spannendes drin.
Naja, kann ja nicht immer was drin sein.
So.
Ähm.
Mal gucken.
PPGA Board.
Pre-Prozessor Brain Fuck.
Äh.
Brain Fuck gebe ich mir heute nicht.
Kennst du Django?
Ja, kenne ich.
Ich habe aber nie was mitgemacht.
Das einzige, was sich zu Django, was mir da spontan einfällt, ist, dass sie so ein
eingebautes Dashboard Zeugs haben.
So.
Ja, Leute.
Gibt es noch irgendwas?
Ich muss gleich mal schauen, was da drin ist.
Oh.
Ich bleibe gleich auf.
Ich habe ja eigentlich gesagt, nur eine Stunde ganz, ganz kurz erstreamen.
Weil ich keinen Bock mehr habe auf noch eine Runde CRANK BUSTER.
64 Spieler mit massig vielen Tickets.
Habe ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen?
Nö.
Sieht nicht so aus.
PPFed.
Wann ist das Apple Event?
Ich glaube, nächste Woche.
War heute oder morgen Nacht?
War EA Play.
Kann das sein?
Apple ist nächste Woche.
Nee, morgen Nacht.
Moment, ist das heute Nacht?
1 Uhr?
Oder ist das morgen Nacht?
1 Uhr.
Das EA Play Event.
Aber das ist mir zu spät.
Da, da, das streme ich nicht.
1 Uhr Freitag, okay.
Nee, das ist mir, das ist mir zu spät.
1 Uhr Freitag bedeutet ja, der Freitag kommt noch und ich muss arbeiten.
Tschüss, mein Name, mich wundert nichts mehr.
Das ist nächste Woche, die Apple-Geschichte.
Das gucken wir uns an zusammen.
Ob da wieder Monitor-Ständer für 1.000 Euro präsentiert werden.
Apple streme ich, ja.
Mail an die IHK, ah ja, nee, das habe ich, nicht an die IHK, an den U-Form-Verlag.
Mache ich noch.
Bin echt mal gespannt, was die antworten.
Hattest du damals explizit für den Visoteil deiner Prüfung gelernt?
Ach.
Ja.
Ja, ich habe halt fertige Prüfung gemacht, da war auch Viso dabei.
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen, aber ich glaube, ich kenne das, die Story mit der Wiese, die heute ganz anders aussieht.
Ich habe halt ganz normal Prüfung gemacht, da war halt der Visoteil mit dabei.
Ich habe so großen Pogen um die ganze Viso-Geschichte gemacht, ihr wisst, ich halte von BWL-Geschichten.
Ist nicht mein Fall, ja.
Wie stehst du zu Rechnungswesen?
Naja.
Ja.
Ich habe mal gelernt, wie man eine Bilanz macht und wie man solches bucht von Hand und sowas, aber nicht, dass es mir gefällt.
Das muss echt nicht sein.
Wie, ich weiß noch, wie man diesen Saldo-Strich macht, da hat die, man musste doch, Leute, wie hieß das, wenn man so ein T-Konto hat, da musste man doch, wenn unten Platz auf der Seite ist, musste man doch irgendwie so einen Strich drunter machen oder so, ne?
Kann das sein?
Das muss man doch irgendwie so entwerten, ne?
Und das musste genau so sein, sonst, sonst geht's nicht.
Ah, BWL-Zeug, hör mal auf.
Die Buchungsnase.
Heißt das wirklich Buchungsnase?
Tatsächlich.
Fuck, das heißt Buchungsnase.
Die Buchungsnase.
Guckt es euch an.
Ja, den Scheiß habe ich mal gelernt.
Wie man das macht.
Für alle, die es nicht gemacht haben, ihr habt absolut nichts verpasst.
Größter Scheiß überhaupt.
Richtig dumm.
Also zumindest nichts für mich.
Was zum Teufel ist ein T-Konto?
Sowas hier.
Soll haben.
Konto 1, Konto 2.
Sowas da.
Ist ein T-Konto.
Will man nicht wissen.
Glaub mir, das will man eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Es wird nicht.
Es ist wirklich so eine Sache.
Die habe ich zwar mal gelernt, aber ich bin froh, dass ich damit nichts zu tun habe.
Ne, ne, da bin ich froh, dass ich nichts mehr damit zu tun habe.
Am Freitag ist Prüfung.
Danach rentiert es sich fast nicht mehr.
Das ist zu spät.
Bis zum Freitag schaffen die es bestimmt nicht, darauf zu antworten.
Aber nächstes Jahr ist auch wieder Abschlussprüfung.
Wobei, ne, dieses Jahr ist sogar noch Weihnachtsabschlussprüfung oder halt Winterabschlussprüfung.
Nun ja, Leute.
Es ist 22 Uhr.
Ich habe ja gesagt, heute nur ganz kurzer Stream.
Ähm, was, was sagst du zum Altersunterschied im Zusammenhang mit Lohn?
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Ja, was soll ich dazu sagen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, wenn, wenn es dazu führt, dass die Leute dann auch die Sachen besser können.
Äh, mehr Erfahrung haben.
Oder im Zweifelsfall, wenn es einfach nur im Tarifvertrag steht.
Warum nicht?
Ist doch okay.
Ja, Loku, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil es entweder im Vertrag, also weil es wahrscheinlich im Tarifvertrag steht.
Ähm, wenn du dich damit nicht abfinden willst, kann ich das auch verstehen.
Und dann sagst du, ich sehe es nicht ein.
Da habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch keine Gedanken zugemacht bis jetzt.
Da habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken zugemacht.
Ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde.
Wobei mehr Geld eigentlich immer gut ist.
Aber im Zweifelsfall wird es eher dazu führen, dass nicht du mehr kriegst, sondern alle weniger.
Also wenn sich das so durch die Bank durchsetzen würde.
So Leute, ich bin müde.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Wir sehen uns bis morgen oder so. Mal gucken.
Bis dann, see you.
Tschüss.